[Music]
don't be scared guys it's me happy
Halloween or happy
three days after Halloween are happy six
months after Halloween whenever you're
clicking on this we're talking horror
movies specifically underrated ones and
we have a super cool panel here and talk
with us about it
he was Jason freakin Voorhees and Friday
the 13th he was also in Predators and
Hansel Gretel witch hunters Derek Mears
and he's the head mad monster at mad
monster calm Evan magar welcome back
buddy wanted to talk horror movies today
and especially underrated horror movies
horror movies that should have gotten a
little more dude I'll throw it out there
first that I love Rob Zombie's Devil's
Rejects that's one of my favorite horror
movies because it's got like this gritty
1970s grindhouse feel to it or your fan
of this movie at all bad these
characters are gritty they're real
they're more real than we like Rob
Zombie characters all the same they're
just like long haired white trash a lot
of people will debate the the Halloween
remake and but I will don't like the
Halloween remake but I personally do
because it's almost it's a traditional
John Carper's Halloween which is
fantastic it's Rob Zombie's Halloween
it's his version so Derek you would say
that
zombies Halloween is underrated agree
yes another one that I wanted to throw
out there
it's a Japanese film called audition I
don't want to give too much away but
this guy thinks he's found the ideal
woman and it's one of those films where
it's building up and you know something
is horribly wrong and you're just
waiting you're white-knuckling and the
payoff actually frickin pays off I'm on
board good pick I want to hear some more
from you fellas Evan I'm gonna go with
Tom Hollands Fright Night just amazing
cast so it it's basically a vampire
lives across the street vampire lives
next door with his ghoul buddy and his
kids a real jerk he keeps getting into
vampires business vampires just trying
to be left alone to his thing one thing
I really like about that movie is that
it's like
classic vampire it's not a teenybopper
vampire lost boys is what started the
whole Twilight feel I don't know I was a
dark guy near dark does not get enough
love that's a fantastic Severin bill
Paxson's vampire new dark you know he'll
take out you know David and the whole
clan and lost boys Derrick is there
another film that you feel hasn't gotten
enough love man I don't know why I dead
snow isn't bigger than it is it's a
Norwegian Nazi Zombies in the snow movie
what I like about like dead snow is it's
traditionally like a throwback practical
effects like 80s kind of style slasher
movie you have the intense kills and and
the over-the-top blood effects but so
much so that I become slapstick II I
don't wanna give it away people haven't
seen I go see it son no dead snow yeah
Evan is there not another one the author
I mean we can do this all we got we
gotta just throw out extras 3 both
Exorcist sequels don't get enough love
they're kind of dismissed after the
first one why do you think that it X's
is to needs to be buried and forgotten
okay after Exorcist 2 is such an
abomination everyone's like we're done
with this series so Exorcist 3 was this
just gem that just a lot of people just
skimmed over because they're like after
Exorcist ooh I'm done if they called
that film Legion and or just had a new
title I think it would've done a lot
better I've been watching personally
like so many like horrible like if it
has like one star on Netflix I mean yeah
I'm on board let's check that out
oh it's so much fun to watch bad movies
and so much I had to watch a bunch of M
night Shyamalan movies for one of our
screen junkies episodes it was it was
painful and wonderful at the same time
that when he produced but didn't direct
wasn't too bad devil boom you heard it
here first an underrated M night
Shyamalan film Shama was actually a good
guy he could say himself he got such a
better I worked him I did science I
played the a the creature on the roof
woman I water the thing is like as an
actor when you work on a film you don't
know what's gonna be amazing or horrible
you never never know there's so many
different elements and working cogs in
the film I personally I like science but
you never know it's Halloween night
you're gonna watch one movie what's it
gonna be
carpenters the thing I love the thing
probably Carpenter's Halloween I know
it's not the most original choice but
it's just what I find myself if it's on
I just lock into it that's a film I
don't turn away from Carpenter's
Halloween on Halloween kind of like It's
a Wonderful Life on Christmas exactly
yeah you're not going wrong with that
guys that was fun and I think I kind of
learned a little bit there that was
awesome
hey what is your most underrated horror
movie let us know in the comments
section below best answer gets a $25
Best Buy gift card brought to you by
cinema now from Best Buy
again I want to thank Derek Mears Evan
magar I want to thank you for watching
hit me up on Twitter I'm Hal Rudnick bye
bye hey screen junkies if you like my
voice how about clicking that big
subscribe button that huh
also wanna see Lucius Fox himself read
the Fox then click the box to the left
to see us waste Morgan Freeman Robert De
Niro Michael Douglas and Kevin Klein's
time reading dumb stuff